late Monday night freshman congressman
congresswoman congresswoman the
Alexandria Casa Cortez found herself in
some hot water when she said this about
the migrant detention centers at our
borders the United States is running
concentration camps on our southern
border and that is exactly what they are
I want to talk to the people that are
concerned enough with humanity to say
that we should not that never again mean
something well the comments were not
just inartful they were an insult to the
millions who died in the concentration
camps many who survived and the millions
across the globe who were trying to
ensure that an atrocity like the
Holocaust never happens again
but instead of saying well she misspoke
or apologizing she keeps digging the
deadly definition of concentration camps
targeting a community
[Music]
putting them in detention camps and
that's what the government is doing and
today Acacio Cortez remains unrepentant
tweeting in part I will never apologize
for calling these camps what they are
now in the wake of all those comments
the most prominent and apolitical Jewish
organizations in the world spoke out yad
vashem the world center for Holocaust
research and documentation offered this
clarification for Acacio Cortez via
Twitter a OSI concentration camps
assured a slave labor supply to help in
the Nazi war effort even as the
brutality of life inside the camp's
helped assure the ultimate goal of
extermination through labor but on the
other side many of Acacio Cortez's
Democratic peers and the media they
sprinted to her defense I agree with the
sentiment behind what she said which is
that we can't take this as normal the
truth is we are creating concentration
camps on the border in 1930
concentration camps in 1941 they were
death camps and that is where we are
going if our conscience is are not
quickly Pierce amazing but this sequence
of events might be the most jarring when
Republican congresswoman Liz Cheney
suggested Acacio Cortez learn her
history MSNBC host Chris Hayes stepped
in for some what does the left call it
mansplaining telling Cheney quote if you
spend a few minutes learning some actual
history you will find out that
concentration camps are different from
death camps and have a history that both
predates and extends far past the Nazis
to that the actual Twitter account for
the museum dedicated to Auschwitz and
the memorial hit back at Hayes and
recommended that he quote please
consider following at Auschwitz Museum
where every day we commemorate and
educate about the tragic human history
of Auschwitz now one might think being
called out by one of the more solemn
historical museums and the
planet would have stopped him and his
tracks yet hours later on a show Hayes
invited a guest on to play defense for
him I would say that for 40 years before
Auschwitz we had concentration camps
things that were called concentration
camps what we're doing now fits very
cleanly inside that tradition very
clearly inside that tradition now you
ask yourselves this is the United States
indiscriminately rounding up just people
based on on color of their skin or
ethnicity and sending them to these
camps no are we temporarily holding
people who are coming over the border
illegally or of their own volition yes
we are sadly though this is just part of
a larger effort we've documented this on
the show the president's enemies are
trying to situate not just this policy
but his entire presidency somewhere near
Berlin circa 1940 now here is an
illuminating conversation between CNN's
Chris Cuomo and Don Lemon about the
network's decision to cut away from
trumps 2020 reelection launched last
night think about the despicable people
we've had in history okay now I'm going
to use an extreme example think about
Hitler if you could look back on in
history would you say well I'm so glad
that that person was allowed a platform
so that they could spread their hate and
propaganda in lies or would you say it
probably wasn't the right thing to do to
spread that because you knew in the
moment that that was a bad person and
they were doing bad things not only were
they hurting people they were killing
people it starts with little lies that
become bigger lies shocker that his
ratings are not stratospheric now it's
so transparent you know what they're
doing it's it's actually sad it's
infuriating but it's also sad I mean
these people can't be this dumb okay so
the only thing you think of is it's just
really pernicious which is really
depressing
within 24 hours just as the president
announces 2020 relaunch Democrats and
their media allies are hurling attacks
against this administration
they conjure up some of the most
horrible atrocities ever committed
against humankind so for the left when
you don't have an argument what do you
do well slander will always do but
invoking the Holocaust to score
political points they're really just
there are no words even for CNN is this
no words you have to be better than that
those propagating these disgusting
smears should not only be ashamed for
the pain and the real division they're
causing but they should apologize in the
name of common decency and to the memory
of those who died that's the angle